welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
dude looks like a lady and in this video
we're breaking down everything you need
to know about lady loki
episode two had me wondering whether i'd
[ __ ] me
and there's a lot of questions
surrounding the character
so bad now we're gonna be discussing not
only her origins
but also what we think might be
happening in the show there's also a
clue that she might actually be another
character from the marvel universe
but as she's going as a loki variant in
the meantime i think we should discuss
her comic book roots
lady loki was first teased in the series
by the release of press material
which stated that loki was gender fluid
this is something that is true to the
comics and the character has appeared in
a number of things
including vol loki doran loki and loki
agent of asgard
however she first popped up as a fully
fledged character after the events of
ragnarok
now loki is of course based on the norse
tricks to god of the same name
throughout the legends he was known as a
shape-shifter that would alter his
appearance in order to deceive people
and in several of the myths he appeared
as an elderly woman he was not
ordinary god and the myths are where a
lot of the inspiration for his
shape-shifting
comes from the character has been
reinvented over the years
and this has meant that he's had a long
and rich history that's led to several
variants in different versions
however the main one was getting very
one note and looking back over the
decades there weren't really any massive
standout loki stories that showed the
potential of what the character could be
marvel felt that he was getting a bit
stale and after being filed countless
times
the comic book creators decided to take
loki in a brand new
hotter direction now in order to talk
about her origins
we have to travel back to ragnarok
construction of asgard and most of its
people
i'm sorry yes very sad in marvel comics
loki was prophesied to lead asgard's
enemies to bring ragnarok to fruition
and he and thor went head to head now
speaking of heads
thor actually pulled loki's head off his
body and hung it on his belt so that he
could watch the passing of ragnarok
ragnarok is very much a part of the life
cycle of asgard and thus
it was always inevitable though it was
under the impression that everyone had
died out
but he soon realized that their spirits
had been displaced and
absorbed into other bodies after
speaking with his alter ego donald blake
what thor realized that it was his
mission to reunite the asgardians
and after finding heimdall he used his
eyes to locate the other lost souls
it became clear pretty early on that
these were indeed continuations of the
older characters
so if you're a fan of the past versions
you can still follow your favorites
and now feel attracted to them too
now thor believed that he tracked down
sith but instead
this was revealed to be loki whose
spirit was inhabiting the body of the
one
she was intended to take over loki
seemed to be a changed man
literally and she said that she was now
reborn with a new mentality
that meant she would become a force for
good thor was cautious at first but he
did learn to trust her
however when it comes to loki you should
always expect the expected
and it was revealed that she actually
had nefarious plans
now this was during a time in which
norman osborne had gained control of
shield
and he ended up replacing tony stark as
the director
this arc was known as dark rain and it
came in the aftermath of secret invasion
in case you haven't read that scrolls
basically transformed into the heroes
and pretended to be them
which fooled a lot of people and it
meant that those in power
couldn't really be trusted lady loki
actually convinced the asgardians into
believing that beta ray bill was a
scroll
and it led to a lot of issues internally
now why they chose to put norman osborn
in charge i have no idea
but i suppose looking at his cv he had
experience leading the sinister six
so we'll forget about all that bad stuff
and when can you start
osborne quickly formed an evil super
team called the cabal
which was made up of members like lady
loki emma frost
neymar dr doom in the hood here she
allied herself with dr doom
and it was revealed that the pair
planned to resurrect the enemies of
asgard
osborne himself also wanted to launch a
new world order
and he joined the wc dub sorry wrong
person
he promised to put asgard back at where
it belonged and this was of course a
very attractive idea to those that just
been displaced because of the events of
ragnarok
loki was still desperate to rule and it
turned out that she had traveled back in
time to alter events so that boar
aka the father of odin could be
resurrected after his death
in the present loki brought him back to
life and enchanted him so that he
believed everyone was his enemy
he went on a rampage and thor ended up
killing him
however this was seen as a capital crime
because boar was technically the king
due to still being alive thus thor had
killed the king of asgard
and he was banished from their community
because of what their laws decreed
though was kicked out of asgardian
society and because of this he wasn't
able to be king
and thus loki had manipulated events so
that she was a successor to the throne
of asgard
a big war with asgard ended up happening
and loki returned to his male form with
sif
being restored too loki ended up dying
and his spirit was reborn in paris
and he became a child pickpocket in the
city this led to him dying once more
and we got the events of loki agent of
asgard this sort of
inspired the show a bit and in that loki
was working for the all mother
attempting to right the wrongs of his
past by being a force for good
it was very much his second chance and
there were alternate versions of loki
running around
which i think very much inspires what we
see in the series
the comic even inspired the design of
lady loki somewhat
as in that he had half a horn on his
crown which she does too
when we eventually meet her now in
episode 2 we are shown
several alternate versions of loki
including a hulk one
as well as a tour de france winner we're
also informed that each loki has
slightly different powers
so we can't really use his typical skill
set to say exactly what abilities she
possesses
in the episode we see her possessing a
brand new power
which involves possessing people this
can be passed on by touch
and it means that she's able to jump
from body to body whilst evading capture
it turns out lady loki has been lying
low during apocalyptic events
in which there were no survivors because
of this no matter what action she takes
there won't be a nexus point created
because nothing will matter
and thus the tva will never be aware of
what's going on
now it turns out that she's been
ambushing the tva throughout time in
order to collect reset charges
so that she can launch them throughout
the time stream as bombs in order to
massively alter history
this will completely overwhelm the tva
and when they're out and about pruning
branches in the multiverse it will
weaken their grip and allow for them to
sneak
in whilst they're at their weakest we
learned that c20 had given away how to
find them
i think that next time we will find out
her origin story in the mcu
there seems to be a big moment in the
trailer where both she and loki are
sitting down
at what seems like an apocalyptic event
and the pair are discussing something
i think this will probably be her life
story but man i don't want to do too
many theories as
this video could end up being out of
date in less than a week
we did see at the end of episode 2 that
lady loki sent a bomb to voromir
so who knows if this has a knock-on
effect anyway she's mainly been used as
a way for loki to play with people
and almost show off that he's able to
change form so easily
involve loki he transformed into the
character in order to be a campaign
manager
when meeting a woman covering the story
this was clearly done as a ploy
as it would be easier for women to see
eye to eye with one another over issues
that were being covered
an agent of asgard this was done as a
way to show that loki could take on any
form he wished
and the character featured towards the
end of the series as loki was trying to
decide whether to return or not
in thor and loki double trouble issue 3
lady loki also appeared with a device
that allowed her to travel through
doorways into alternate dimensions
now i might have just wasted your time
with the character and she could
actually be another person from the
marvel universe
however the reason the tva aren't
showing up right now to wipe you out
is because you are always supposed to
waste your time watching this video
much in the same way that you were
always supposed to like it
this is your glorious purpose brother
rejoice
now in the international versions of
episode 2 the show comes with credits
that state that varian is actually
called selfie
we put the two versions of them on
screen right now so you can see the
differences
and in case you don't know sylvie went
on to become the enchantress in the
marvel universe
no not that one yet idiot now sylvie was
born in oklahoma which is of course
a location we've already visited in the
show with her
so it does make sense sylvie actually
gained her powers from loki
and she shares several abilities that
are similar to his
so it could indeed be salvi pretending
to be loki or it could actually be
mephisto using loki's body
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on lady loki and what you think
will be happening in the show
as to thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
straw on the 30th of june in which we're
giving away three copies of the mcu
phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the character
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
come to me else to watch them make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
second episode which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over all the easter eggs and
things you might have missed
so definitely check it out if you want
something else to watch without the way
thank you for saying through this i've
been poor i'll see you next time
take care